good morning Millennials and happy
Wednesday hope everybody's having like
the best day that they could possibly be
having given the circumstances I hope
that your day is going as well as it
could possibly go right hey Jax how you
doing I'm doing okay I look forward to
another day of trying to buoy humanity
and the Jewish Community yeah because
that is our role to play in the war to
amongst others but I think it's a very
important role and it helps me I think
it helps and it helps a lot of people so
I am committed to doing that while still
talking about what's going on talking
about the celebrity element and sharing
resources for how you can help 100% you
just reminded me of somebody like not to
change a subject so swiftly on you um we
started a list yesterday of phrases like
we need to start saying more regularly
and just things we need to start
remembering and I had one
okay is the blank in the room with us
yeah that's something that you saw on
Tik Tok it's it's not like I saw on Tik
Tok it's just like what what people say
on Tik Tok and you like it you
incorporate it like yeah it's like when
someone like okay Jackie tell me
like hold on tell me like that you feel
really beautiful today like you'd be
like I look really beautiful today no
cuz I feel like you're going to like
just can you say it for the the way that
you're phrases it sounds like you're
about to make fun of me okay
say be like I look so [__] I I keep I
can't like explain this the way
okay no okay this isn't buoying watching
you stutter and fumble no it's like when
somebody brags like oh my God I'm having
such a hard time explaining like the
proper use of this phrase am I okay is
the blank in the room with
us like maybe you could find the Tik Tok
you saw it in and share it it's not like
a one time Tik Tok it's just like when
somebody on Tik Tok brags like look how
you know fancy my my room looks and
someone will comment is the fanciness in
the room with us okay that's a good is a
good example yeah no it's so funny and I
probably should learn how to properly
use it before I try to like start adding
it to my weekly ver vernacular and
disseminating it yeah I'm sorry I
totally botched it can somebody like
write a good comment explaining it and
so you were going to make fun of me it's
the beauty in the room with us yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not falling for
that but it wasn't about you it was it
was hypothetical I understand I just
feel like there were other situations
that could be less hurtful so do you
want to add it to the list you didn't
make the best case for but I'll do it
because I love you and you're my sister
and we're 50/50 and if it's important to
you it's important to me wow I love that
energy
also I need to talk about things that
are booing us is the blank in the room
yeah what's because I have a few things
to help buoy you one my episode of the
redheads is out Claud listened to it
this morning and the comedian herself
said it was comedy gold it was really
funny how funny are we just really
really good I think we need to move to
the comedy
category it's highly competitive it is
but the redheads there's nothing like
them nobody can beat them yeah but also
the redheads kind of like put out that
episode without posting anything else
about like the war in Israel no I heard
that the redheads are very
anti-israel you could possibly think
that because we've been silent or
silenced radio Silence from the redheads
disgusting and we put out that episode
not even acknowledging what's going on
so if you think maybe the redheads don't
stand with Israel I'm here to tell you
that we absolutely do I run our
Instagram account and all of my efforts
are being put towards my personal the
toast but I do need to make a statement
from the from the redheads plus dropping
an episode like in the middle of a war
without context could seem insensitive
seem insensitive no you should also
actually now I'm being serious like put
together I saw Emily help reads a list
of books for anybody who wants to like
know more about the conflict or just
like you know uh learn about the Jewish
people and the struggle je history yes
that is my plan but you know the
redheads are Instagram's very C curated
so I have to make the cards and as
stated like I've just had a lot going on
but that is priority today for sure the
episode's 30 minutes so it's just like a
nice I listen to it while was J my hair
this morning a nice little treat if you
just want some light-hearted fodder plus
I'm also on straight up with Joy podcast
and that's another little treat if you
want some light-hearted f it was a
really fun episode Claudia was like
sitting next to me while I recorded it I
was sitting right here and Jackie was
sitting right there so the voice of
Claudia is in the episode I'm constantly
like asking her wait Claude what about
this yeah that kind of makes the episode
worth listening to yeah for tur's
influence voice when you're done
listening to the toast today and you
still need to be booed there's two more
podcasts that you can listen to with
your girl and I think it's important to
have things to look forward to I agree
um I feel like yes yesterday um I was
actually like I I needed things to buoy
me like I had a really bad night last
night like I I feel like people always
say and it's something I've never been
able to relate to like when they're
stricken with grief or just like going
through really hard times like I can't
sleep I can't eat like for me in my life
and no matter what I've been going
through like I can always sleep and I
can always
eat I I was shook when I weighed myself
this morning like not in the way that
I'm usually shook I cannot eat I'm
nauseous all the time I literally woke
up I I literally thought I was pregnant
like I fell asleep nauseous and I woke
up nauseous I feel physically ill like
yesterday was just like a yesterday we
were together a lot and so I feel like
we were like I feel good when I'm with
other people but like the second I got
home I was literally not okay like
physically or emotionally um so like I
need the toast CH buy me today like I'm
like I'm sick we are going to do our
best and I feel like we have been doing
as good a job as we possibly can given
that there's so much on our minds and on
our
hearts and so we're just going to keep
it real with you guys about how we're
feeling I'm wearing this Cowboy
sweatshirt today cuz it's the only
sweatshirt I brought to New York with me
I don't know if the Cowboys made a
statement um if they didn't I would
won't be wearing it again I'm sure that
they did I Googled it I said Dallas
Cowboys Israel but there's a player
named Israel and he came up so I said
Dallas Cowboys Kamas nothing came up I
never thought I'd be Googling Dallas
Cowboys Kamas I don't think Kamas
thought they you'd ever be Googling
Dallas Cowboys Hamas I don't think the
Cowboys thought I'd ever be Googling
Dallas Cowboys Hamas but so many sports
teams have come out strong in support of
Israel so you know i' honestly assume
that they have like if the Cowboys
haven't there are so many teams for me
to be a fan of right now I'm so
impressed by the Sports World yeah the
Sports World for before a lot of games
have been you know having moments of
Silence like it's it's very um I know it
feels like meaningless and performative
but I I actually really don't agree I
think seeing things like that bring me
great comfort just knowing like there's
10,000 people or however many are in a
stadium or baseball field like who all
like know that this is wrong like that
actually brings me great comfort and I
find maybe what other people would refer
to as perform performative activism like
it brings me great comfort yeah I
totally agree everyone there was like a
huge Israeli flag in that basball game
that video went around also I wanted to
talk about something cuz I feel like
when people talk about performative
activism they always talk about the
black square and everyone's like
remember the black Square we're not
doing this anymore I didn't feel that
way about the black Square can I tell
you what how I saw the black square like
when I woke up that day I forget which
day it was but it was it was Thursday
nobody was posting anything other than a
black square and my entire Instagram
feed was black squares people who I
follow you know in my personal life who
never post at all who just use Instagram
passively never post I've never seen a
post of theirs every single post was a
black Square I did not see one other
piece of content from an influencer or a
person no ads nothing self-promotional
and it felt like an international day of
morning and I remember feeling like wow
if this if people ever did this for the
Jews how much that would mean to me you
know it I I completely agree now I think
it's like it's dismissed as performative
but I I remember I didn't interpret it
that way I remember exper experiencing
it as like we're not distracted we're
not talking about literally anything
else than this and it was extremely
powerful I agree I think now like people
remark on it differently but at the time
I feel like at the time people didn't
appreciate it either and then they
thought that it was like taking away
from the messaging of the movement cuz
then Instagram was flooded but I just
felt like I would like you you had to
pay attention yeah no I I completely
agree so I don't like I don't feel that
way about social media activis even just
posting up a card like it I think it
means something and it matters to me
yeah no as someone on the other side
like I I feel like you can't it's all
good yeah like I don't really see how
and we're not even saying like stop
posting your coffee and your lip balm
and your ads I know it's Prime day you
guys have commitments I did yeah but
like you can post where you stand yeah
no I I agree with you and if you're not
posting anything at all none of those
things then you don't have to post
anything right no it's not a requirement
and I kind of feel like I'm I'm
struggling with so many like internal
conflicts yeah because I find myself
like being like judgmental and like
shame sh like police shame like post
post shaming people in my head no I'm
not you know a little bit on the toast
too a little bit on my Instagram yeah
yeah yeah actually I'm definitely and
like I I feel like I'm turning into like
a person who's annoying and someone I
would like hate but it's like it's
conflicting feelings I understand that
but what happened was so egregious an
evil we've never seen in our lifetimes
in this Century ever inconceivable evil
so I want to know the people that I
follow and the people that I know like
is this ambiguous for you I don't want
to know you I don't want to follow you
it's so true like when when you break it
down like you're right and the people
who come on with like statements of like
six slides it's like sh I don't I don't
need to hear your verbal diarrhea like I
need to know where you stand stand like
that's it Y no totally and I don't need
to hear why you can't tell me where you
stand or why I don't need to hear where
you stand yeah no I I do need to know
like which of my friends are going to
justify and excuse terrorism like I
absolutely need to know for sure and I
think it's really important to know like
in no way do I think that everything
else should stop no and I think we'll
talk about not that it could I think
we'll talk about that with our first
story We bar get people to just scam
with Israel unequivocally without the
butt at the end of the sentence let
alone to stop posting their nonsense and
some of the nonsense is buoying so I'm
not even asking that yeah no and I don't
think that's required and I don't know
if it would necessarily even be like you
know more helpful I think it's perfectly
fine find to like the rules of social
media are so bizarre and they're so
fluid and they're always changing but
like in this moment I feel like it
really is okay to continue to go on with
your life especially if your job is
influencing content creating being a
celebrity putting out content I think
that is fine but I do think it's you
know also important to just announce
where you stand like are Are you ashamed
of where you stand and there are so many
Graphics that I've seen that don't say
much but they say enough the one that's
like you don't have to be Jewish you
don't have to be Israeli you just have
to be human when I see that agreed you
just have to be human yeah it is inhuman
to see what we saw to have that not be
enough for you to doubt what you've seen
to say oh this is fake news this is
propaganda it's like everyone is
doubting this like baby claim because
they won't release pictures it's like
how badly do you want to see decapitated
babies and they released a picture today
so it's really graphic if you're on
social media they released a picture
like that's how much doubt was cast upon
this like first they just told us about
it and people didn't then natany showed
President Biden pictures he came on and
he said I saw it Biden confirmed
yesterday that he saw it and people were
like he
mumbled what so they posted a picture
where if you need to see a picture which
I don't think most of you do but if you
if you do need to see it in order to
believe it where was it posted it's on
Twitter you you could find it okay it's
really really upsetting I didn't see it
did you see it I saw uh somebody had
like blocked out some of it so I all
like part
okay um so
yes there's enough information out there
for you to to get a grasp on what's
going on and I think to not address it
is just it's it's an interesting take
it's an interesting take and I feel like
so many people are like I don't want to
take up space with my post on this no
you should up take up you know what
takes up space those six slides I have
to spend time reading that everybody
else shares and hides behind so I've got
to read it again yeah that's taking up
time and space yeah shove it up your
ass jackieo went there she went there
unless you're saying something like if
you're saying I saw a statement that
literally said nothing I know said
absolutely nothing that is taking up
space no the font is so you're better
off not saying anything seriously like
no shade because you've just said
nothing no you sound dumb it was like I
with the people of the world and I love
oceans I love oceans it was the craziest
thing I've ever seen it came from an
account that you wouldn't expect
anything more it was like words are
vibrations was one of those accounts one
of those accounts third eye shop crop no
I like third eye thoughts Third Eye
Blind I love third eye thoughts they're
really introspective I don't need to
hear from third eye thoughts on this
matter right right right right right um
so like what
else what else we have some celeb news
we have some celeb X War news celebex
for and that's what we do here because
we know you're all sitting around doing
the same thing and I just want to say I
like I know we have I've heard a lot
from um toasters who live or visiting
Israel and they said the toast is booing
them so like we are committed to being
as funny as possible today for them yeah
which we always are we don't even have
to try we don't even have to try I feel
like when we try that's like when it's
not funny it's so true and I I kind of
feel myself trying no no yesterday I was
like not trying and we were so funny
yesterday it is what it is thought like
wartime episodes being some of the best
they're so important yeah shall we like
I guess I guess it is time for the fast
five stories that you need to know you
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by pillsberry if you're a mom if
you're a busy gal or guy uh week night
dinner can be a struggle it's hard to be
creative it's hard to keep it fun but
that's where Pillsbury and their
delicious crescents come in you can
transform a Pillsbury Crescent with
delicious ingredients that are going to
make it a side a side dish or a main
dish so if you're feeling like you're
just overwhelmed but you still want a
delicious gorgeous dinner for your
family for your husband for your kids
whatever it is pillsberry crescents are
the thing for you there's so many
different options for all different
types of diets all different types of
restrictions you know I know there's a
lot of people who love to do like pizza
and cheese and pepperoni while I'm not
Kosher I respect that for you but I
could do sauce and cheese no no can I um
if you want to check out a lot of the
recipes that are going to be fabulous
for dinner night rotations
find a bunch of recipes at pillsbury.com
you can do chicken bacon ranch crescent
rolls you can do ham and cheese crescent
rolls pillsberry is just saving busy
people everywhere you can find
pillsberry in the dairy aisle and it's
dinner prep in 30 minutes or less and
especially want to shout out the picky
eaters myself included it's really great
and fun and easy to experiment with the
pillsberry crescents and make something
for the picky eater in your life like I
said I am the picky eater in my life so
find Pillsbury crescents in the dairy
aisle and get to dinner prep in 30
minutes or less you will not regret
always having these on hand in your home
because you know dinner time comes fast
5:00 it's like oh what are eating and
everyone's looking at you well you're
looking at Pillsbury Crescent so again
find them in the dairy aisle and just
have a gorgeous delicious dinner for
your family today's episode is also
brought to you by battered fertility
think back to sexed for a moment you
probably learned all about how to
prevent pregnancy but what about how to
plan for it if you've always been a big
fan of planning ahead like we have you
know you schedule trips months in
advance plotting out your next career
move you should be doing the same for
kids so the traditional Guidance with
fertility has always been just to wait
and see but modern fertility is changing
that it's an easy and affordable way to
test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple a simple finger prick mail
it in with a prepaid label and you'll
get your personalized results within six
business days you can get insight into
your hormone levels like your ovarian
reserve and other important factors that
can impact your fertility the results go
deep into what every hormone means and
you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
hormone testing at a fertility clinic
can cost over $600 but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
for only
$179 and if you go to Modern
fertility.com toast you can get $20 off
your test plus you can get reimbursed
for the test through your FSA or your
HSA which is fabulous so if you want
kids today or maybe one day in the
future clinically sound information
about your body can help you make the
decision that's right for you because
the toast and modern fertility both
believe that knowledge is power and
fertility is no different it's so
important to know what's going on in
your body so right now modern fertility
is offering our listeners $20 off the
test when you go to Modern fertility.com
toast that means your test will cost
$159 which is a fraction of what it
would cost at a fertility clinic get $20
off your fertility test when you go to
Modern fertility.com
toast that's modern fertility.com
well you're kind of like being relaxed
with the iPad recently CL I'm in no rush
plus like you know it's hard for us to
find things to talk about so I'm taking
my time make the episode long it is
really hard for us to find things to
talk about okay the first story what
everyone's talking about in celebex war
news Taylor Swift Forge ahead with her
dumbass movie premiere has yet to say
anything about anything going on in the
world she had the Swift eras tour
concert film Premiere in Los Angeles
smiling on the red carpet with her celeb
friends posting videos with beyon yet to
mention um slaughterfest 2023 yeah
so I have like literally not been able
to process this like when I was on my
Instagram yesterday and she posted like
a picture of her and her outfit which
was heinous getting ready for like I was
I was floored like I understand that
this is an event that's been planned and
like you're not you don't need to cancel
it no and that's what we just said like
you have your work commitments do your
thing for sure and she hasn't said
anything and even if you're not going to
say anything to post about it on like on
Instagram like for me just takes it to
another level like have the event you
want to stay silent fine still stay
silent but to post about it on Instagram
like I don't know I was just shook
beyond words and my lack of interest in
this story is like Beyond me cuz this is
a week ago I would have had so much to
say about Beyonce oh oh yes yes yes like
it's fabulous everyone keeps pitting
them against each other Beyonce looked
[__] amazing
like I could go on but honestly like
it's one of the craziest it does anyone
else not like this is crazy no no it's
crazy and you said yesterday Taylor
doesn't speak on these issues so you
don't expect her to speak but she does
she does you know you're right I uh the
Swifty the Jewish f50s like and I have
been chatting
and they're like no for for many many
many many years she never said one thing
about one thing ever and then that
started to backfire on her and then I
think kind of performatively she started
like picking and choosing kind of safe
causes um and putting a lot of energy
behind it and she actually got like a
lot of backlash for it especially from
the queer Community because it felt just
like inauthentic um to like make it your
brand right and no I had forgotten about
that like she she in recent years and it
was covered a lot in her documentary now
I've spoken to the Jewish swifties and
we are like Crest Fallen like for real
um and there has been like a a theory
going around which I I do think has
validity and I'll shed some light on it
um you know tiller speaking out is huge
bigger than any celebrity ever um she's
you know actively on a world tour and I
think it could be a possible concern she
talked about it in the documentary um
about her safety you know taking a
stands against a terrorist organization
one of the most powerful people in the
globe who's going to be traveling around
the world in in the coming year I guess
that's fair who wants to tell our Kamas
doesn't care if you stand with them or
against them like they're coming for you
just the same so so factual no it's
factual I just wanted to share with the
Jewish 50s like we're I've seen that
we're struggling I've seen that theory
and and we're grasping at straws I know
and you guys are getting really creative
and I think that there's probably some
Merit and some fear maybe but you also
have to you know have a spine no for
sure and honestly I was really shook
because I I didn't really put together I
wasn't thinking about the fact that it
was era's night launch like I just
wasn't it wasn't on my radar and the
first thing I saw was that Instagram
post and then when I was on Twitter I
saw a picture of Marin Morris and I've
been monitoring Marin Morris because
she's like a very vocal Queen she
actually we didn't even talk about it on
the toast but like she it was kind of
misleading cuz she like did it and the
media like kind of misinterpreted then
she went on a podcast and said like kind
of but she basically said like I'm
formally leaving like the country music
industry like my music will still be
country but I'm not releasing it with
country record labels anymore like I
don't want to be a part of the Nashville
crew because I find country music just
to be like hypocritical and they don't
stand for equality and she thinks
they're spineless like there's obviously
just politics like a difference of a
politics there and that was her you know
big moment when she like a week or two
ago and I've been looking at Marin
Mars's page not
promoting excuse me not promoting hasn't
said a word yeah promoting her
children's book
who would dare how dare she who would
dare she could promote it in between you
know her statement I was shocked because
she just made this huge um pronouncement
and and the reason for her leaving is
like you know her Progressive beliefs
and that none of that aligns with the
country music world and it's like well
here you go right this was not
Progressive do you have something to say
about about the women being raped right
about a country that I I read something
crazy today that the 93% of people in
Gaza um are against hom [__]
homosexuality 93% they said it was the
highest in the world so like it's not
Progressive no that's what I'm saying so
like I that Mar Marsing like really
struck me I was like wow I like just her
her presence there I was like yeah I was
shook and also I think it's high time we
start talking about what happened
between Kelsey ballerini and Taylor
Swift I saw a video on Tik Tok before
the war BW where um Taylor was uh Kelsey
was on a red carpet and she was asked
like what do you think about Travis and
Kelsey and she was like oh I think it's
great I hosted SNL with and I love
Travis and you know Taylor and I were
close for many many years we're close
for many many years and the comments
were like
were and now it feels like Taylor's like
new you know country girl BFF is bar is
Marin yeah but is that surprising how
many were close friends did T has Taylor
had wow like now we can be honest yeah
no I really like might be 50 no she
definitely has a lot of you know coming
and going she has a lot of room Roman
Empires yeah with girl you used to be
friends with so back to Beyonce and
Taylor Al also worth noting Beyonce has
not said a word right um so I don't know
this gave me nothing like this is
something I would have like seriously
like died over especially because
Beyonce looks so gorgeous yeah it would
have been a great moment for women but
we just had like a really bad moment for
women so maybe we could have like women
like this picture still talking about
that there's no serotonin like my brain
doesn't there's no wave activity when
seeing this this photo it's enormously
disappointing yeah and I'm struggling
with how to Grapple like seriously I'm
really struggling yeah the Jewish 50s
are not [__] okay I will give you
space and time thank you like please
don't come at like no I know you're
loving this no I'm not I'm not I would
have loved for her MH to be the queen
that we need her to be speaking of wait
wait wait wait what are you going to say
kings and queens no but save that you
know who was at the eras tour that like
a lot of people are talking about is
Adam Sandler right cuz he's like pretty
much like the most prominent Jewish
celebrity who is so proudly Jewish and
everything he does and he's been and
he's not like a person who releases
statements like he's just a dad but like
he's not an influencer he's not an
Instagram we don't like wait to me he's
not required like he's not required and
I imagine I just watched his movie and I
I've seen quotes about him talking about
Israel like he loves did a big Howard
Stern thing once so I believe he's
someone who is you know his role is not
Instagram influencing I'm sure he is
helping in behind the scenes in his
personal life we all have a role to play
in the war to come yeah yeah so I I have
no issue at the moment but I'm saying
like I I have to imagine if like you
know Taylor was like a Hamas lover Adam
wouldn't have gone like they know each
other personally I don't know I'm really
struggling like I'm grasping at straws
no I don't think it's that I think you
know his daughters probably really
wanted to go yeah and he went okay
speaking of kings and queens so
interesting and like the T the way that
this show has just like changed in the
last week is so crazy because Kate
Middleton Prince William and King
Charles put out a statement yesterday um
about the war they said the prince and
princess of Wales are profoundly
distressed by the devastating events
that have unfolded in the past days the
horrors inflicted by hamas's terrorist
attack upon Israel are appalling they
utterly condemn them as Israel exercises
Its Right of self-defense all Israelis
in pal Palestinians will continue to be
stalked by grief fanger anger fear and
anger and fer and fanger in the time to
come a very strong statement a very
strong statement and we were saying
yesterday how Megan and Harry were on
their mental health World Tour they
haven't said much you know they like to
speak out for causes and especially like
humanitarian crises such as this crisis
and they put out a statement yesterday
too after will and Cate after will and
Cate and I have to imagine like will and
Kate's statement lit a fire under their
tushies no the timing like I guess but a
lot of people you know a lot yesterday
was a big day for a lot of people who
couldn't really ignore it for much
longer they said at the archwell
foundation with Prince Harry and Megan
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex we stand
against all acts of terrorism and
brutality we are supporting our partners
and organizations on the front lines in
Israel to provide the urgent aid needed
and to help all innocent victims of this
unconscionable level of human suffering
no this the thing like I knew Markle and
her Sparkle would show up like Rachel
Zayn would never not show up like I
like I this again brings me great
comfort these are people with so much
influence like these are like AAA a list
like I always think think of them on the
same level as Michelle and Barack like
former dignitaries of sorts you know
yeah former like heads of state and I
don't know I feel like they all just go
like Martha's Vineyard together
diplomats yeah um and you know Barack
Obama put out something really strong
too like I think these are people with
enormous influence like all over the
country not just in like Elite circles
you know um and I'm grateful I really
really am so grateful so appreciative of
this strong statement from Megan and
Harry in the ranking of beloved
celebrities on this show Megan has now
surpassed Taylor Swift I'm telling you
and if you had told me that last week
like by the way next week you guys are
going to be so here for Megan Markle and
so not here for if you told I could have
told you the Megan Markle thing like
I've been telling you you need to watch
suits like oh yeah I'm sure she I I just
I knew it like she's a [__] Queen
well former princess queen she's a queen
like that's my [__] right there I love
her yeah so that's some good celebrity
ex Warriors I just want to say like I
still find Harry annoying like I'm sorry
yeah but you know what doing the right
thing no all all beef is squashed no
it's so true like the media landscape is
forever changed for me for me and it it
should be yeah yeah speaking of the
media landscape um sag Afra oh my God
are back to negotiations as Studios
suspend negotiations so talks between
sag Afra and the major Studios have
broken down as the alliance of motion
picture and TV producers said Wednesday
that the gap between the sides is too
great in a statement to members after
midnight the union accused Studios of
engaging in Bully tactics and said that
the studios had walked away from the
bargaining Table after refusing to
counter the Union's latest offer like a
couple of weeks ago we were told it's
going to be any day now like we're good
we're we're pretty much there just dot
the te's sign the eyes yeah but that was
about the writers no that was about the
actors the writers were confirmed and
then they're like and sag is imminent
sag is three 4 days away that's what
they said so now the Studios have walked
away from the
table but the writers are good like the
writers are back at work okay happy for
the writers what does this mean for the
actors like are we going to get all new
actors now I don't know or like maybe a
new different Union like maybe people
who want to go back to work and and are
fine accepting less because it's all
they can get they're like listen we we
got to work so I don't I honestly like I
have no idea
um I don't know like and now how long
has this been going on was it July
that's a really long yeah and like
thankfully most of the TV I watch is
like the nanny like shows that the
friends Sex in the City like I've just
been to watch like the same five shows
um but like people got to work this
ain't cool yeah you know I am you know
going to an event that FR rusher
scheduled to be at next week maybe I'll
just ask her like Franny what up yeah
wait I just put together Franny the
Annie even though they call her
Fran they should have been called the
Franny yeah that's how she became the
Franny so but also like I guess writers
a lot of writers write for TV shows with
actors but a lot of writers write for
like daytime so so I feel like some of
the writers who are now probably not
striking anymore still don't have work
because they write unscripted shows
right that sucks yeah it's all one
organism right right and I feel like sag
went on strike in solidarity with
wga and
now they're alone on strike yeah but
they had their own things to worry about
too for sure for sure for sure you don't
just like on strike for nothing yeah so
who knows the SAG saga continues to
confound maybe Fran like will drop out
of the event CU she's now like so busy
like it's it sounds like her schedule
just freed up they're done negotiating
they walked away yeah but she is like a
union town answer to you
know like thousands of members
yeah I'll let you guys know if I see her
I think that you will I mean the
Studio's walked away so either she has
to come back like with her tail between
her legs or actors are going to leave
the union or new actors are going to get
jobs that they wouldn't have gotten yeah
at this moment in time like I can't
believe this is still going on if you
ever wanted to be a movie star like
really now is your
time yeah but the the dangers of that
they say it's like if you're wanting to
be a movie star
um you can like technically take
advantage of this strike if you're not
in Sag and get a role you never would
have gotten because no eligible sag
person is around H if you do that you're
immediately like blacklisted from sag so
if sag remains and I'm sure it will like
this prestigious Union that you have to
be a part of and you acted this way
during the strike #the sag remembers I
think that there's going to be a coup
within sag of actors who cannot take
this first of all people who actually
like need to work the smaller actors
they'll start get and they could also
say like hey if we defect we could get
these bigger roles I think that's what's
going to happen that's usually what
happens like Lord of the Flies energy
yeah however I do think sag um has a big
fund that a lot of like the one% of like
they say like 99% of people in Sag don't
make more than I think $26,000 a year
but that 1% of people make hundreds of
millions and but it behooves them to
keep paying that fund so those people
don't take their parts right open your
eyes so lot of big actors are um keeping
them at $26,000 salaries I was going to
say a lot of big actors are contributing
to the fund to keep them at
26,000 taking their million dollar
salaries and by the way I don't know how
much really longer that fund can go on
paying like 100,000 People's rent bills
for the first couple of weeks it was
like noble and but now it's
like how much money is that a lot yeah I
don't know I think we're going to see
the SAG turn on each other what is the
new sag called
hag yeah sag oh no
sag I'm not
okay there's other oh my God I was not
saying
that wag wag bring back wag z z are you
ready for our next story yeah some odd
celebrity news Sharon Osborne says she
and Aussie still have an assisted
suicide packed in place that's so them
the talk show host uh Sharon
initially addressed what show is she on
um she was on The Talk The Talk but
she's not anymore no she's on AIC yes
and she's spoken about that she said she
lost too much weight same she initially
addressed the subject in her 2007 Memoir
Survivor my story where she said that
the couple would go to the Swiss
physician assisted suicide organization
dignitas should either of them ever
suffer from dementia the topic surfed
once again on the latest episode of the
Osborne's podcast which features the
whole family during the conversation
Jack inquired if euthanasia was still a
plan for his parents euthanasia is such
a crazy word yeah I guess assisted
suicide is euthanasia however euthanasia
makes me think of dogs and the
Holocaust why didn't they euthanize
people in the Holocaust they killed them
it wasn't a mercy gassing people
euthanization no it's just murder oh
okay like so what's euthanization it's
like when you kill someone prematurely
of spare them yes oh oh okay never mind
so then I think of dogs yes dogs
euthanized yes so Sharon replied do you
think that we're going to suffer aren't
we already suffering and he uh said yes
we all she said yes we all are but I
don't want it to actually hurt as well
mental suffering is enough pain without
physical so if you've got mental and
physical see you and then Kelly said but
what if you could survive and Sharon
said yeah survive dementia Sharon said
yeah what if you survive and you can't
wipe your own ass you're pissing
everywhere [__] can't
eat I just want to say I'm not laughing
at the side effects dementia is horrible
I'm laughing at you saying [__]
yourself I got to listen to this
podcast this story begs a larger
question let's talk about the osborns
like they have been famous for as long
as I've been watch I can't talk about
the osores without Kelly Osborne on The
View I can't talk about the osbornes
without saying
Sharon you I didn't know about that
Kelly Osborne on the view clip how about
that Donald Trump I [__] love that
moment It's the funniest thing and when
he sent it to me it was the most
shocking thing I ever saw if you've
never seen just Google uh Kelly I keep
almost saying Kelly Clarkson Kelly
Osborne The View Trump oh my God it's 10
seconds and the video just does not end
how you think it's going to
end it's the craziest thing I've ever
seen I can't believe she still works
yeah but I guess her parents go maybe
Google Kelly osor toilet no Claudia like
everyone knows everyone knows I'm sure
if I Google interet will know what
you're looking for if I go to Kelly
Osborne on Google like and I see related
searches like it's going to be Kelly
Osborne The View and I don't want to
spoil it for you guys and I don't want
to ruin it Kelly Osborne 2023 baby
weight loss oh
wait view it's the it's buried she's a
team of people working on it it's buried
probably it's there like but you have to
write the whole thing out got it you
have to find it um but it really I I
think we should just take a like a step
back and and think about the osborns at
large like they are famous because he
was in a band called Black Sabbath very
very very very successful and him and
Sharon became like this iconic Rock and
then they had kids and then they had the
reality show and like I just don't know
why like they're all famous still like
it's just like crazy to me no yeah what
does Jack do right oh that was an actual
question no right right Google like he
does what every like nepo kid does stuff
projects and such projects of of that
nature projects of that nature
understood I just I think it's crazy
that like all these people are famous do
you know what I mean yeah yeah but there
like but that's what for for a very long
time in this country like that's what
America loved like families of famous
people like their show on on E was
around the same time as the Kardashians
like there was an obsession with like
family reality shows there are not even
just famous people like all those TLC
shows yes yes yes yes yes Stacy Kate
Stacy and Darcy Silva yeah are those 600
no no that's Tammy and Amy thousand
pound sisters they're not thousand pound
anymore what are they I would say
collectively I don't want to guess
someone's weight but how they lost the
weight yeah how like one did and then
the other was like put on a ventilator
I'm not sure like it was
honestly how did they lose it I think
one of them them got surgery but like
one of them I honestly I don't know I
don't keep up with the th000 PB I prefer
to watch 600 lb life individual stories
got it but they got their own show Tammy
and Amy right right it's a crazy name
for a
show it I actually I actually remember
the first time I saw it in my TV
Guide I was flored no TLC goes hard no
and you know what like they have a niche
and they kill it like who would you say
competes with TLC for like Freak Show
they're like they find people with like
with like the biggest pimples ever on
their backs and give them their own
shows about what it's like to live with
a pimple that big like it's a circus no
but like Netflix hasn't even like they
they see what TLC does and they're not
even trying to copy it like that's how
much of a lock they have that's singular
their Niche is yeah some of their shows
like the titles like at first they
started innocently like Toddlers and
Tiaras and John and Kate Plus Eight then
they had like the Duggers with 19 Kids
and Counting and Counting cuz like they
were constantly you know [__] and
then they just like honestly I need to
Google like craziest shows TLC has ever
produced okay because I feel like you
wouldn't believe
it unless TLC
ever I mean who could forget Breaking
Amish right who could also forget
extreme cheap skates oh yeah hoarders
hoarders buying naked are you familiar
with that no oh I've seen this sex Sent
Me to the ER dramatizations it's it's
like people's stories that they
dramatize I Didn't Know I Was Pregnant
yep yep yep yep yep yep Best Funeral
Ever okay wait screenrant.com the 10
weirdest TLC shows of all oh excuse me
it's not even on here Mike Strange
Addiction oh my God extreme coup hunting
I want to say that's one of the best
shows on TV we could all learn a lot
from those people um Here Comes Honey
Boo Boo hoarding buried
alive DUI perhaps one of the most
forgettable series DUI was a production
in the same v as cops or live PD in
which television Crews chronicled the
arrests and persecutions prosecutions
excuse me of Oklahoma residents caught
driving while intoxicated Oklahoma's
notorious for its stringent DUI laws in
the series highlighted the stresses and
consequences of those working their way
through the court system after being
arrested Breaking Amish extreme cheap
skates buying naked house hunting shows
are incredibly popular and when combined
with feuding couples or unexpected
expenses the ups and downs of the
housing market can make for surprisingly
exciting TV but in 2013 TLC decided to
take a step further
by debuting of course they did by
debuting a series that focused on the
house hunting experiences of nudest
couples oh my oh I should be on the show
Freaky
Eaters a program that highlighted
individuals struggling to absolve
themselves of a regular eating habits
from a man who hoarded more than 100
gallons of maple syrup in his home to a
woman who habitually drank up to 30 cans
of soda per day me um aired for two
seasons oh my God this cannot be a real
show my teen is pregnant and so am I
My Strange Addiction it's like MTV like
had team mom yeah they just have to take
it so far they just have to obsessed
like I I really respect and applaud
their Ingenuity and constant creativity
yeah at to finding like the craziest
people in the country like what their
writer room is like and like the ideas
that are they don't have oh oh oh not
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
they're creative they think tank we're
doing a brainstorm like what's the
craziest show we could do yeah like new
development team yeah that would be just
insane
am I being
called who's calling now it's the iPad
the iPad's no the iPad's here it's my
computer oh says you're calling me what
oh no sorry never mind sorry someone
else okay my phone like didn't update
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by sax.com we Jackie and I are
always doing our best when it comes to
looking fabulous on the podcast and
thankfully there's video proof that
sometimes that's not always the case
sometimes it's a slay but sometimes it's
a nay sometimes our pajam uniforms and
sweatshirts do need a little bit of an
upgrade and that's why Jackie and I love
shopping at sax.com for everything from
podcast looks to gno fits and more
honestly sax has become my go-to
destination for like businesswoman
outfits whether it's a panel or a
meeting or I'm going to La and I have
like a bunch of things going on next
week I'm heading to sax.com for
everything day to night start to finish
it's fabulous sax.com is super fun and
easy to shop on so whether you're
looking for that cozy Vibe which is the
season thank God and or a more elevated
look they've got it all at sax.com
and what I love most about sex.com is
the way you can like filter through
their uh offerings based on you know if
you're going on vacation you're looking
for workoutfits a cocktail they also
have a great um wedding guest section
and they're getting really specific you
can even shop at sax.com by your star
sign you can find the perfect Revenge
dress from Brands like Christopher esber
and cult Gia I also love tx.com is just
a way to find Fabulous new brands
because I feel like the buyers there are
all really Chic and they know what's
going on so if it's on sax.com it's like
approved and then tury can wear it and
it's like sax approved
so discover new ways to shop for
everything every day fall wardrobe
Staples that you should always have in
your closet good things to invest in
that you'll have for years to come and
it's really easy to shop for everything
every day at sax.com that's
saks.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by game time you should not have to
worry about when you're buying tickets
for your next big event and game time is
the fast and easy way to buy tickets for
all the sports music comedy and Theater
events near you with killer last minute
deals all in prices views from your seat
and their best price guante game time
takes the guesswork out of buying
tickets game time is the only ticketing
app that gives you complete peace of
mind with your purchase you can see the
view from your seat before you buy it so
you know exactly what to expect what's
worse than that like getting that little
View and it's wrong and then you show up
and your seats suck not with game time
they're all in pricing shows your total
upfront that's also a terrible part of
buying tickets like oh this is a good
price boom boom click click it's tripled
in price because of the fees not with
game time they're all in pricing shows
you your total upfront you know what
you're getting without hidden fees and
you can buy tick tickets in second with
two Taps I love to have game time on my
phone at all times because if I'm
traveling or even if I'm in New York
there's so many fabulous things going on
game time is a great resource to use
being like what should we do tonight I
don't know let's head to game time with
Zone deals you can also pick the section
and Game Time picks the seats for an
average of 18% savings and for me the
best part is the game time guarantee
that means you are always getting the
best price and if you find tickets in
the same section in row for Less game
time is going to credit you
110% of the difference so take the
guesswork out of buying tickets with
Game Time download the game time app
create account and use code toast for
$20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
t o a St for $20 off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guadan thank you game time for
sponsoring today's episode of the toast
enjoy the rest of the episode are you
ready for our next story I guess give me
a second this popup won't go
away Teresa Jud judice and her daughters
Teresa daughters Teresa and her
daughters slammed for partnering with
problematic fast fashion brand so Teresa
and three of her daughters face backlash
for partnering with fast fashion
retailer Sheen Teresa and all of her
daughters shared a video posing in
several dresses matching sets and
pajamas for their Juda girls ex Sheen
collab they said we're so excited to
finally announce our partnership with
Sheen official to create the ultimate
why saying it like Sheena like Sheena sh
Sheen because if it was up to me I would
say shine so I'm trying to get it right
say shine shine shine on girl it's sh
what am I saying sheen sheen no it's s h
e i n there's no reason the company's
name that like Sheen it maybe she in she
out that's what I was thinking like she
in but like that's not even a good name
if your company name is so like is
causing so much disruption in discourse
you need to reevaluate a lot of things
they do cause disruption in discourse
and they're not reevaluating but I
should watch your video to see how the
daughers pronounce it but they said all
it's a ultimate pre- holiday collection
they said all the pieces are reflection
of us very glittery and gold lots of
glamorous fun and Chic styles that are
perfect for everyone we even made to
made sure to include comfy and Lux
sleepware for your next girls night in
so while several fans have flocked to
congratulate the women several others
criticize them for working with Sheen as
the company has been accused of
unethical business practices and copying
work of other designers someone said why
she in though one of if not the most
problematic clothing lines there is I
guess the shoe fits [__] rude someone
said she and is some of the cheapest
junkiest clothes it's fitting this is
mean I have a hot take here oh wow
because you know I'm not like Teresa's
fan no um first of all everyone works
with Sheen like why is it coming down on
the daughters they're just like trying
to be like industrial self-starting
women they got to this is the brand that
gave them a collab and they took it no
and by the way maybe not everyone works
with Sheen but they work with a
different variety fashion R pretty
little thing Asos like all who really do
this H&M all who really NOA really
fashion Nova all who Sheen takes the
brunt of it but they all have very
similar business practices that are
problematic yeah that are fast fashioned
that are copying other people that are
made of crap that are bad for the
environment why is this coming down on
the judaist girls' shoulders who are
just trying to like provide for their
families I'm sure they still like
restitution they're not turning down
business opportunities this is not their
problem AG I agree like Fast fashion
falling on the shoulders of milania Juda
Gabriella Juda Gabriella Juda it feels
wrong it feels wrong feels misplaced and
to be honest I think like this is a
great fit for them brand wise like yeah
who who if not Teresa and her daughters
like is going to do a brand collab with
Sheen you know yeah Kara fagy is not
going to do it no and it's a big
opportunity for them they are like
little influencers on their own this is
probably the kind of clothes they wear
this is the kind of clothes their
followers wear like if you want to take
on Fast fashion like don't start with
the little person who's just trying to
like you know pay back their restitution
right no and if we want to talk about
about fast fashion like we also need to
talk about like the lack of options
otherwise like I don't see a a ton of
ethically made $10 shirts I don't see by
the way especially when I like needed to
shop for bigger sizes like good luck
getting anything in a 14 or above that's
not made in a sweat shop like we we need
to wear clothes yeah so like let's talk
about lack of options it's not like she
could have done a partnership with
another company that makes you know
ethically sourced resp responsibly
affordable clothing like there aren't
options yeah so if we want to like go in
on Fast fashion there's a conversation
to be had here like I don't think the
Judas is to be at the table I don't
think tearing the good judice name down
is going to is going to be helpful here
it's not going be been there enough
haven't they been there enough not me
think defending Sheen today yeah or the
judices crazy but just crazy things
happen every day on the show no and it's
like we're we're things are just being
put in perspective yeah so I think this
is mean those those tweets were mean
like you can comment on the state of
fast fashion without saying it's
fitting yeah then I'm not taking you
seriously cuz you're mean it's so
true so I stand with the Judes today and
the Jews we stand with the Jew dices we
do our I think that needs to be our
title the judices standing with the
judices like JW
right unless you don't think it would
translate verbally orally I don't know
it might be confusing we'll take a look
yeah we assess after maybe there's
something yet to come that would make an
amazing title The Best Is Yet To Come
our fifth and final story mhm the
winning Powerball jackpot ticket worth $
1.76 5 billion sold in California this
is the second largest prize ever always
in [__] California the fourth billion
dollar jackpot in history all of them
sold in California what you mean all of
them they're going to have to split it
no no no all of the billion dollar
jackpots are from California we need a
documentary on this like it's giving
mcop mcmillions mcmillions not enough
people talk about like it's always
California and I understand like if
there have been $4 billion prizes and
California is so big maybe two of them
like I understand how population ratios
work suspicious I have a I have a
thought one California is a huge state
so population ratios as you said but
let's talk
about the people of California you know
they're a city of dreamers La is the
city of dreams they might just be a more
lotto ticket buying town no California
is so big like north to south like La is
not even California and by way it's
never sold in La proper it's like always
like somewhere completely random no but
maybe the heart of the Californian
people is to dream and everyone else in
the country is like more realistic
they're like you know this is a waste of
money stroke like to dream they're
dreamers their dreams came true no and
the rest of the country maybe is a
little more sensible so you're saying
they manifested it and nobody else did
that sounds like they're buying lotto
tickets and no one else not no one
else's but they're buying more lotto
tickets like per capita than the rest of
the country because like they souls are
The Souls of dreamers no like I'm
telling you nobody on the planet is
buying more lotto tickets than people in
Florida like that's just a fact well
they also win too a lot they're also a
big steep what is it no I know what
you're saying by the way like lottery
tickets and like being obsess with
Lottery kind of person it's cultural
like it definitely is I completely agree
I'm just not buying that the dreamers of
California proper are dreaming this into
existence like I'm just not buying it no
they're just like buying at a higher
volume their probability is higher
because they are of the elk who dream
they are of the elk who dream no let me
ask you another question get your iPad
back what's considered the poorest state
in the country in terms of like is that
a stat like GDP kind of I'm yes I'm sure
can I guess sure do you want to yeah I
feel like they can get you canceled like
no I think this West Virginia um this is
by the poverty rate but that's not what
we're saying no I guess poverty be by
individual who cares what the you know
legislation has there I want to say West
Virginia H they're making me download
the graphic hold on wait uh the
Port Mississippi yeah that's what I'm
seeing on this graphic interesting and
then West and then New Mexico and then
Arkansas no mississippi Louisiana New
Mexico Arkansas West Virginia okay that
was a good guess by me yeah so I would
expect like more dreamer
mentality from the poor states like
would that have high poverty rates
dreaming is
priceless can't put a price on the dream
it's just it's a it's a me like it's not
about it's not about that it's not about
statistics it's about dreams like it's
just about
like like rich or poor you can dream you
know it doesn't have to be you don't
have to have a certain amount or not a
certain amount to dream like it's free
dreaming is free okay so you're arguing
against yourself because if dreaming is
free then everyone would equally dream
that's true wow and not it wouldn't be
specific to California that's a good
point but I just think that they are the
elk who
dream I think they have dreamer Souls
the El who
dream you know what Jackie I agree they
dare to dream I feel like even in those
like commercial California propaganda
commercials with are like come it's
great I I'm so glad you brought that up
I feel like it's like California like we
got a dream and then he's like on the
server skateboard yeah what is up with
like States having commercials like and
I want to say I've only seen it for
California Michigan and New York well
cuz they're suffering but I also seen it
I think for North Dakota never no never
and it's I get that it's like a bid to
increase for South Dakota to increase
tourism and people moving there you know
and that increases revenue and creates
jobs like I totally get the mathematics
but like the concept of a state having a
commercial is so like just goes against
everything I believe and understand you
know yeah it's I remember the first time
I saw it Michigan went [__] hard
where like it was a river and then the
river turned into the word Michigan like
they went so hard with their propaganda
like they were the first ones to do it I
will give them the credit for being like
you know thought leaders thought leaders
in their field but it's something I
really can't get on board with that's
like when you talked about hospitals
that have commercials weird I feel like
I didn't realize it because it's not
like there's so many hospitals that it's
like you know what this one have better
commercials I'm going to go to that one
like you always go to like the one
that's closest right I guess not
everything's always an emergency and you
do get to choose yeah but you would
choose based on your doctor and your
doctor choose like for an OBGYN it's
like your hospital is associate your
doctor is associated with the hospital
yeah but also I never realized this and
I'll explain when I did realize it but
um drugs companies commercials it's like
don't you just take what you don't go to
your doctor be like I saw a commercial
for this for astroica yeah it's so weird
and I didn't even notice that until
people in the UK were watching Megan and
Harry on Oprah and all the commercials
like for drug companies they were like
oh they don't have that there they don't
have that there and then it made me see
a differ I'm like by the way that's an
amazing point I don't like go to my
neurologist and say I saw a commercial
for this migraine medication actually
though first first of all first of all
speaking of migraines nobody is doing
more than ner Tech otd yeah Lady Gaga
and Khloe Kardashian as their sponsors
like I mean spokes people I'm a migraine
sufferer and I I I still haven't like
brought it up to to my doctor okay but
you know what because I trust my doctor
more than Lady Gaga and Khloe Kardashian
don't you feel like that might be
changing now like with OIC like that's a
drug people are requesting to be on
whereas before like they would go in
with an ailment and say give me the best
stuff right OIC isn't even getting like
the ner Tech otd treatment it's actually
getting the opposite yeah but they and
they by the way they do have commercials
oh oh o obsessed talk to your and but
even their commercials don't address it
being used as a treatment for weight
loss it's all about um insulin
resistance yeah so that's a very
interesting point and I love that Megan
and Harry brought that to us m in
addition to a strong statement yesterday
yeah what else is weird that they have
commercials
for during the Super Bowl remember there
was like a commercial for Jesus oh yeah
but I think in the end that ended up
being like a commercial for like a
nonprofit or something yes I also think
that commercials in
general it's just like who's actually
influenced by this commercial like is
this really going to change what brand
of cookies I'm going to buy as a species
we are so evolved past commercials like
traditional TV commercials there are
some things if it's a new product and I
see a commercial for it like I might be
you know helped but like to see a
commercial for d like I either want to
buy Doritos or I don't at this point
like I've tasted them I know when I want
a Dorito so I feel like with a Dorito
like I think I put them in the category
of like clor rocks like they're doing
the commercials seriously like just to
keep up appearances like it's not it's
expensive yeah but like the they have
the all in like this Rat Race cuz I
guess if Doritos dropped off but like
other chips out I might forget about
Doritos right I mean I could never but I
know what you're saying it just it makes
me think all the time like you guys
don't need a Super Bowl commercial like
that's a lot of money don't it I
actually disagree but of course donate M
but it's a rat race is what it is yeah
when I think of commercials but to me
there's no marketing more effective than
a Super Bowl commercial when done right
but even for Doritos because no I I
think there is like like the farmer dog
commercial like a new brand you're
hearing about it and it tugs at your
heart but for Doritos it's like I'm
either going to eat Doritos or I'm not
no because it's it's a brand awareness
like an image thing like Doritos is such
a cool brand like I always feel like
they're partnering with cool people
because they're keeping up appearances
like it's a cool Factor yeah is it
effective it must be like it must be I
think for some products and businesses
it's so effective and for others I just
feel like it's a waste of like Oreos
like I either want an Oreo or I don't
and your commercial is not going to
change that but the thing is do you ever
not want an Oreo if I'm like picking out
cookies in the AIS like if it's going to
be Oreo or chips aoy like that decision
is not going to be suede based on a
commercial no cuz it's always going to
be an entiments and entiments doesn't
run commercials but they're also like
not as popular because they don't have
to but they're not as popular because
they don't run commercials I am or or
because it's a smaller business it's a
smaller business because they don't run
commercials it makes you think it makes
you think and that's your marketing
segment with Jackson turd yeah so that's
our show more questions and answers but
that's like kind of the toast in in its
Essence well we just ask questions never
stop asking why never stop asking
questions so that's our show right yeah
all from me thank you guys so much
tomorrow's episode will be Audio Only
only so just wanted to keep that in mind
for everyone hope everyone's having a uh
what thank you so much for listening to
the toast Mill Morning Show where we
deliver the fast fact stories you need
to know every Monday Friday on YouTube
so you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available to podcast any we podcast we
found repast listen podcast us toast
leave five starie about a beautiful
standing and wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow I'm love you
bye